What's wrong? >> What do you mean? Does he not know? >> Here
we go.
>> What the
>> Look at me in my eyes. >> Did you say something
racist?
>> I just pulled up
my phone. >> Yeah, you shouldn't. Don't look at my
>> Let go of my phone. >> Gina is smiling because
she knows she is in full control. >> It just depends on
how people accidentally [laughter]
Dude, Zena has almost as much power as I do.
[music]
Wait, there's all kinds of cool drama happen. Oh [__]
we got all kinds of things. I need to write something down before
I forget it, though. Hold on.
Also, remember the incident where And then I'm not going to say
it on stream anymore. Shalom.
>> I think uh I think Clips von Claus has that, right?
What you were talking >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I think somebody linked that to me.
Ice Poseidon's New Year's Eve Leefest.
Let's [__] go. >> Yeah, I didn't see this thing
until like five minutes in. >> Yeah, but we need the context.
Okay, we got to do all the context here. >> No, like the
it's it it doesn't you're not getting context for the big drama
for like half the video.
But am I going to like this? Who's WSM?
>> the context starts at like 3 minutes in. >> Who's
WSM? Who is that? >> Westside Mike. >> Westside.
Oh, okay. Hold on. I I I'm sorry. I got to watch from the beginning.
Please just let me watch from the beginning. I got to see it.
Okay, >> sure. It it just doesn't pertain to anything.
It's like the most boring alive. Someone like steals a beanie
and must gets in like a his Uber. It's like >> it's an
ISIS Uber. Okay, hold on. And then people steal a beanie and
then Shui is in big trouble. Is that where this actually starts?
>> I need to listen. I need to >> I had to milk out
hours in the stream. >> It's going to do it. It's just
boring.
>> Okay. From the from scanning, I thought that was Kimmy
for a second. I was like, "Oh shit." [screaming]
>> It's not, by the way,
>> happy new year.
Oh my god. Maybe >> so awkward. Awesome.
>> I'm so glad we're watching.
>> Are they They like falling asleep.
>> It is happening. Why?
What the >> happy
mother?
>> How the are you in here? >> What's up my >> car?
Bro, >> bro, how are you in here, >> dude? I was
here for the Uber. >> Who was that? >> Your friend.
>> the guy in the trunk. >> Why do you smell like
>> You just let everybody walk in your car. >> Why
do you smell horrendous? >> All right, whatever. Let's
get in. Hold on. I don't care. Let's just get in. Oh, look who
it is.
>> Wait, wait, are you You're walking up with a group of
five people. What is he supposed to know? One of these guys isn't
with you. >> Why you get mad at the Uber driver? >> Look
who it is.
>> You just sneak into people's cars. >> Happy New
Year. >> Appreciate it. >> Yeah, you Bro, the smell
is crazy.
>> Like, you guys are You literally smell >> Okay,
I'm grabbing a drink. 2 seconds. >> We're actually live
outside. Why do you have your light? >> All these guys
want is clouds. actually >> They would even >> loser
screaming to 32 viewers. What are >> you talking about?
You don't even get 30 >> I'm so glad we're watching. >> That's
why you had to snipe a a damn >> The fact No, listen. >> Nobody
likes you, dude. >> Is this your Is this your friend in
the back? Who is that? >> We We
planned this. >> Nobody this
Listen. Sometimes you got to milk content where there's no content
by watching something. that you don't care about for a little
bit longer. Okay, >> just chill. >> It's going to
take it's going to take you 3 hours to get through 5 minutes
of a video.
>> You don't need to watch this. >> You pause every
third.
Okay. That's called transforming content. One. One. That's called
transforming content. Two.
You three. Why are you even here?
>> God damn it. >> You asked me.
Wait, you also asked if I'd seen it, but I did ask you. >> Yeah,
then you said hop on. I was like, "Sure." It was Paul. >> That's
me.
>> Is a certified lover. Can we please burger him?
>> So, he's not with you guys. >> Love you. >> No,
he's Yeah, no, he's not. >> Yeah, you might have to burger
this man. >> Can you like I don't know. >> Can you
get him out? >> Okay. Whatever, dude.
>> I'm trying to figure out how to get into this menu.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> Wait, what is the
super chat? >> Why are you still >> I'll walk there.
You good? >> All right, that was a good one. >> Take
the walk. >> I swear are you still with your girlfriend?
You do realize she will continuously make a fool out of you over
and over. You can do better. She lowike
>> Whatever, dude.
>> I'm trying to figure out how to get into this venue.
Oh, he made it. Ah, I
I feel like that's
Isn't that like super
That feels so
turbo to just be like whatever. I'm going to let that go.
Be like, none of your business. I do what I want. She's I want
to move. >> Just say you're gay and move on. You could
literally just say and keep going. >> Where's your girlfriend?
>> He finally Oh, >> well, that's not good.
All right.
>> How bald is Anthony on a scale of 1 to 10? How bald
is Anthony that he that How do you have that reaction to somebody
taking your >> beanie? 5-year-old streamer. I'm like uninterested
in any stream of his ever. >> How How do you have that
reaction to somebody taking your beanie? That's got to be That's
got to be insane.
>> He's done,
bro. He's done.
>> He's done. The hood's up. He's done. Oh, he's running.
Hood's up. He's done. He's dropping his phone. He's dropping
>> Wait, I think my husband is calling Westside Mike and
Dunle.
>> Food's up. He's getting pressed. Pressing Westside Mike.
>> So, while you go over a beanie being stolen, I'm just
going to
>> I don't know. He got the beanie back pretty fast.
She said three minutes into the video. It's like not even close
to finished >> It's fine, Anthony. It's fine.
>> Hey, come on. It's fine. >> No, bro. >> No,
you're going to go to the hospital. >> This is the guy,
by the way. I got I got banned for watching Darius call this
guy the fsler. Okay, >> that's fine. Let's just go. >> Yeah,
bro. Like, what? He was looking like he wanted to fight Darius
that
>> All right, bro. >> Get back up away from us, too.
>> Go ahead. You want to get smacked? >> I'll take
a ride here. >> Wait. No. If you if you smack him, you'll
get banned. Don't do that. >> Don't get banned, >> bro.
What?
>> Bro, you are If I catch you off stream, it's over.
>> Don't Don't let me catch you off.
>> Who's that, dude?
>> Got snipers. [laughter]
He's got fans. >> All right, we're skipping to the Shuy
>> I saw Shuy talking about his bank account with you the
other day. >> Shuy is literally
>> He's going to go to prison one day.
>> Because of his taxes or what? >> Uh Shuy, he owes
over 100k in taxes. >> He's going to
know how much money he has left, right? >> He I mean, he
showed me. Yeah. >> I mean, I know. Okay,
>> he's he's going to prison like
>> talk to someone else for sake of lame ass Twitch losers
who gives a [__] you and are nonsense from what he
had back
How are Zena and Ice hanging out again after like not being friends
at all for so long?
Hope you've been paying your Canadian taxes. I overpay my taxes.
Okay, I think I'm going to get like 10 grand back this year.
Like 10 or 15 grand back this
I um
I I basically overpaid and I haven't filed my amendments yet.
Like I I massively overpaid because I had to file an amendment
and I didn't want to do it. And then
yeah, so I ma I I think I massively overpaid last year.
So I'm just waiting once I file that amendment and file my tax
return this year. It's going to be crazy. >> Hundreds of
thousands of dollars in taxes. He's going to prison.
>> They're taking his van. They're taking his cars. >> At
least 30k in taxes. From what you've seen, 30K in taxes.
>> Way more than that. >> You think more than that?
>> Uh I He showed me everything he's ever made. He owes
like over 100K.
>> Wait, is this guy 37% minimum? >> Thanksgiving.
So >> is Shu is is Shuy saying he's never paid taxes before
or something? Is that what he's saying?
That's crazy. To make this much money for this long and just
never once pay taxes
is [__] nuts.
>> Unless you do some loopholes, but he ain't doing loopholes.
[laughter]
>> Write off almost everything though cuz he hasn't made
any profit. >> Writing off what? What does he have? >> A
van. >> The $2,000 van. >> 20k subs to Kais. And
let's not count out the money he's given me. You can't write
that. >> Shut up. >> You can't write that home. You
can write >> I mean, if it's on stream, he can write it
off as a business. If you want the >> it was on stream,
so it could be a
>> The Kais donation. No. No way. >> No, he makes
>> He didn't get audited. >> That's true. >> If
he reacted, >> I'm going to report him to the IRS to get
my get my $10,000 bounty. >> Hell no.
>> Bro, watch out. Shuy, >> You get 10,000 for that?
>> You get 10,000 for a bounty. >> Are you kidding
me? >> These guys are actually going to call >> sooner.
I don't for 2026. >> If you report stupid to IRS, you get
10 grand in a bounty. >> I'm joking.
>> Wait, are you joking? Are you serious? >> No,
I'm serious.
>> Just so you know. >> I'm serious. >> Just
so you know. But um you said who?
>> Snoopy. Yeah. Uh,
>> how do they so consistently find new random people I
know nothing about?
>> It's wild.
>> Where did everyone >> Okay, hold on. Hey. Hey,
Beats. Hold on. Hold on.
Who left the door open? >> Who was the last person inside?
Your
>> Better get him straight, bro. >> Hold on a second.
That's fine. You can me up. But if he leaves my door open, that's
>> That's disrespectful. But I don't think it was him,
honestly. >> Well, then he shouldn't have closed the door.
Who was the last person? Right. >> I'll take responsibility.
>> Now, what do I do?
>> Where Where did everyone else go? >> Who's that?
>> That girl was calling Zena racist things. Why is she
here? >> The blonde girl.
>> That girl? Yeah.
>> I don't know. >> She was
like crazy things.
>> Okay. Do you know her? I don't know. >> She know
me. >> Let's rewind a second for something. I >> Oh,
thank you. >> Still with your girlfriend. >> Oh.
[laughter]
>> Uh, w incelss, I guess. Damn. >> Do you realize
she will continuously make a fool out of you over and over? You
can do better. She low IQ.
Whatever. >> Zena's smiling because she knows she is in
full control. >> It just depends on how people act.
>> Dude, Zena has almost as much power as I do. Ice Boseidon
is within Zena's penumbra. Okay. Ice Boseidon does whatever Zena
wants him wants him to do.
>> She told me
>> Zena is smiling because she is in full control. She's
in full control of this
Don't get crowd but like what? >> Yeah, don't
>> I mean yeah I don't even
chill but if she ask my face
>> is Zena racist
>> I have to tell you something.
>> You didn't call me an evil monkey and a 30-year-old
groomer. You didn't call me that? You sure YOU DIDN'T CALL ME
THAT? CUZ I GOT YOUR CAT. >> I think your cousin's getting
impressed. You told me that
>> you wanted beef in the chat. Now you don't want beef.
>> Wait, what the [__] happened? >> I
don't know. >> Did she say that? You >> say what
>> is that?
>> It's my cousin. I don't know what
>> hey, Zena, remember what the message just said. Remember
the message?
>> All right. But she did say that cuz I got the chat log.
>> Do you know her? >> I got the chat logs. YOU A
FAN IN MY CHAT, BABY. All in my ex's chat TALKING ABOUT ME. DEAD
ASS. YOU CALLED me evil MONKEY BABE, BUT NOW YOU BASICALLY got
nothing to say. Maybe sorry or say you troll me. Maybe come on
Zena just say >> Remember remember the messages, Zena.
>> Is Zena not on probation? How how many charges does
this need to catch for her to act right in a public setting on
a stream? Can you just chill, Zena? Can you just chill? What
the
>> I don't want you to go to jail.
No more.
I'm right here. [__] you knew I was >> Did
you say that?
>> Want me to PULL UP THE LAW? >> WHAT DID YOU SAY?
WHY DO YOU think that you say that? >> I got the law.
>> Crazy. I got the law. I got the law. >> Pressing
somebody from the chat. >> Why are you in chat? Did you
say that or did you NOT
my punching me? BUT I I DON'T EVEN
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO
PUNCH HIM.
>> I promise you I will not punch him. >> Did you
say the yes or no answer? >> What happened?
>> It's in the Philippines. Yes. >> It's okay if
you called Zena racist.
>> Wait, what? It's okay if you called Zena a racist? That's
not what anyone's saying. Wait, wait, wait. There's still
Why are you >> Zena literally doesn't have any idea what
anyone's talking about here. Zena literally doesn't know. She
got no clue whatsoever. She's sitting here like, I don't know.
Kimmy says she was racist to me. Sounds like a presser press
her. I bet you I bet you Zena made up every single thing that
she said. Like every Why'd YOU CALL ME LIKE CRAZY MONKEY WOMAN?
She made that up. Okay. She She's basically like, "What does
Darius called me? I'm going to say that this [__]
called me whatever Darius called me.
>> WHY are you racist? >> BECAUSE SHE CALLED ME RACIST
THING. SHE CALLED ME AN EVIL MONKEY. She called me a 30-year-old.
>> Oh, she calls you racy.
I want to make a mad like [__] Look at you. Look
at you. You funny looking. You shake like a goddamn I can't even
say the word. >> Read your chat. Tell them. >> They
said you're worse than Kayn.
>> You're worse than what what did you What did you say
to Zena? What did you say? >> You'll see. What do you mean
you'll see?
What's going on here?
>> Oh my god. What did you say to Zena?
>> She's She's actually
>> I don't know who is. What did you say to
>> Here's one. Big blackie. Here's one. Let me take off
the log. [__] you. >> What? What did this DTS
say? Jesus.
Well, after Ice has said to leave. >> Damn, I almost >> tell
her to say what she said to >> I mean, yeah. I mean, if
she wants you to leave, then go.
>> Which one? >> What do you mean TO OUR NOSE? >> HERE
WE GO. MONKEY.
>> What the
>> Look at me in my eyes. >> DID YOU SAY SOMETHING
RACIST?
>> I just pulled up racist.
>> God, you shouldn't Don't look at my logs. Let go of
my phone. >> I'm not just
>> Okay, so you can go. >> Oh, go off stream. WE'LL
TALK ABOUT it if you typed in my pulled up.
>> Hold the logs for the video. >> [__]
is that you?
>> THAT'S NOT
She's [__] and she just >> look at your
She's like, >> I've never spoken to you. >> If I
leave, who? >> Let's see the logs. >> I just love
the logs. She's calling me a monkey and all of that. She said,
"Oh,
Kiki crazy." Hold on.
I think I think they come into focus. You're just dude.
Zena is a manic psychotic. I can see it in her eyes. Big gang
of squirters. Why is this guy staring at your blank?
>> They're call. >> Please be careful, Shuy. Please
be careful. He keeps looking at you centrally. I think we he
wants to >> monkey all over like
>> monkey monkey monkey 40941.
Okay, hold on. Monkey monkey monkey, she sucks on your monkey.
Are you back? What is this? You back on your monkey humping BS?
Hold on. Let's just pull the logs. Let's just pull the logs.
We don't pull the logs. We're never going to know. Give me a
second. This is a little crazy.
So, hold on. It's um it's in Shu's channel.
It is Kiki crazy. Kiki crazy.
Let's take a look at this. Oh no, no, no. I need to go back further
than this. This is
July. July. July. July. July. July. Hold on. I got to wait for
the search process. Monkey making our own table.
>> Stupid monkey. [__] That [__]
Why are you scared? >> Why are YOU SCARED? >> WHY
DID you spam that?
I told you
>> that wasn't funny. Oh, what the [__] >> Wait,
is Kimmy
Kimmy got no ch? What the [__]
Kimmy Kimmy's like, "Look at me. I'm Zena now. Zena's on probation,
so I'm Zena now. I'm going to do the Zena now. This >> in
my house. Let's >> not do then. Bye. Let's not do that.
>> Let's not do that. >> Okay. Goodbye then. >> Take
your Roblox biting the
dude. Dude. Ah. Please don't look back at Ice and say Ice kick
this [__] out. Please don't look at Ice and go Paul.
You got to kick this [__] out. That That's the worst
thing you could do to him right
That's the worst thing you could do.
Roblox bloody. Yeah, Zena Zena did say it. Yes, Zena did say
with get out of here with your Roblox ass body or something.
>> Let's not do that.
>> Let's not do that. >> Let's not do that. >> Okay.
Goodbye then. >> Let's take your Roblox body in the >> You
can leave the restaurant [laughter] now and leave. >> You're
trespassing now. You can leave. We have guns.
>> Who's we? >> Not we. >> Timmy does. Timmy
[laughter] does. >> No, I say I do.
some blonde girl.
>> What are we talking about?
>> I'm not blonde girl. I'll pick her up and take her out.
She's 4 feet tall.
>> Happy New Year's, guys.
>> Jello Shop. >> Zena wants to write an appeal,
by the way.
[laughter]
>> I'm not doing anything. Y'all stream all day long. What's
wrong with me? She was. >> I'll be real, okay? I've watched
a couple of the past Ice Boseidon streams. They're just infinitely
better when Zena exists. Even though Zena breaks the rules constantly,
Paul should try to get her unbanned cuz the content is just infinitely
better when she's around. Okay, I'm sorry. You You can't complain
about how Zena acts when her when the content is just like infinitely
better when she's there. All right,
I watched you guys complain about a bulletproof vest for like
four hours. It was boring.
This is way better. Even though it seems completely contrived,
even though she was clearly laughing at the comments, she doesn't
she's not actually offended by those things. She's just better.
She just gets violent. She's not getting violent right now. Where's
Where's the violence? She's like getting in somebody's face.
She's not getting violent. Literally >> racist towards
me. I have not said one racist thing towards her. Not one. >> I
called her out for what she did to me. I haven't done to her.
I haven't called her mayonnaise, nothing. I haven't said RACIST
TO HER. [laughter]
I'M SAYING I have not said one thing. I am defending myself about
[__] Why are you trying to be friendly? But you >> She
did hit the phone. That wasn't That wasn't Kimmy. I could have
throw I could have sworn that was Kimmy. >> But maybe it
was Zena. Damn. Zena shouldn't do that. Bad >> to me. What
have I done wrong? I can't. Why are you allowed to talk? >> Yeah,
but you don't have to get in people's faces.
>> Oh yeah, [__] Yeah, [__] I shouldn't
get in people's faces, [__] It's about optics, Zena.
[laughter]
>> But she could just apologize and be like, "Oh, I was
trolling." That's it. And I would be like, "All right." >> Oh,
also, no woman except for Zena can even handle like 1 1,000th
of the CX community throws at them. Okay. Zena's like the only
one who could handle them being all at her and she still shows
up and and is like content. The rest of them would be like all
depressed. They wouldn't stream ever.
You know, it's true. Hold on. Zena the nappyhaired monkey. Oh
my god. Disavaow.
Zena, you monkey. Shut the hell up. Muslim something. Monkey.
Where's the monkey? Where's the monkey? Shuy, where's the monkey?
Zena, ugly, stinky monkey [__]
[__] you, stupid monkey. I'll really punch you in
your
And Zena Zena responded with a shuy. Wait, or was she she was
replying? Sorry, she was replying to Zena with this.
Zena, unban me, you stupid smelly monkey. Shuy, has Zena been
making you wear a monkey do-rag all night? I see waves coming
in with your new hair. Are you back on your monkey humping BS?
Yeah, she's clearly just racist, actually.
Jesus Christ.
She's actually just racist.
>> I love how the white girl was like, "Wait, they're like,
wait, were you racist to Zena?" And she's like, "I don't know.
We'll talk about it after." Zena isn't even black, right? I mean,
she's some kind of Afro Latina, isn't she? I'm pretty sure she
is.
She's not
African, but she's got to be afro Afro >> I'm okay with
you. Actually, sorry. I'm
>> Then I'm fine. Then I'm just [laughter]
>> Stop cracker. >> Then I'm drunk and that's fine.
Do you really just trolling and you're just a chatter? I don't
know. >> You hate black people.
My [laughter] brother is >> Can you admit what you said?
>> Okay. If you're genuinely sorry, then >> Kimmy
Kimmy is doing too much. >> I'm sorry, too. >> Kimmyy's
doing way too much right now. >> We can just go back. We're
good. We're good. We're good. Listen, we're okay. And like I
said, I'm not going to just pitch you. I'm not going to just
pitch
>> But we're okay. Okay. We're good. Yeah, we're okay.
We're good. W clear.
>> What more? What? >> Wait. Hey, Katie.
>> Katie. What's her [__] Hey, come here. Come
here. >> No. Whatever.
>> She was talking to you. >> Walked away. >> Are
you going to admit what you said though? Cuz you kept denying.
>> We cleared up our stuff. >> So, you're not going
to admit stuff? >> We crazy. We cleared up our crazy. >> Is
everything good? >> We're good. No, I have
>> God damn
>> dude. I don't know any of >> how do they cycle
so many new people in? I don't know anybody who's walking into
this party.
People you choose to associate with determine a lot of where
you're going in life. Steve Harvey.
This reminds me of her standing outside the house. I need that.
I need that Zena hoodie picture right now. If anybody's watching,
you got that Zena hoodie picture. I need that right now. Outside
of Darius's house in the middle of the night. Okay. Where is
it? It's the same smile. It's the same goddamn smile. It's the
same one.
Hold on. I'm going to I'm going to save this moment so I can
show you guys if somebody does link it to me. One second. Uh
let me copy the current time and start the video in another tab.
>> Got an ops showing up here.
What this further? Like you're so weird.
>> Duh. It's streaming.
>> Just black out. You won't remember a
>> Little RNR ladies. >> If he called if she called
her crazy. >> Oh, I mean Zena's crazy. Come on. >> Oh,
you think Zena deserves to be called crazy?
I mean, these things are crazy. >> First of all, she has
actually someone sent me a screenshot and said, "You put
>> Yeah. Hold on. We got it. We got it. We got it. It's
like the same pixelated smile. Okay.
She out here. She out here controlling.
She out here controlling
and not saying anything. It's wild.
>> Little RNR ladies. >> If he call if she called
her crazy, >> oh, I mean, Zena's crazy. Come on. Oh, you
think Zena deserves to be called
>> I mean, Zena crazy >> first because actually someone
sent me a screenshot and said, "You put me as non." And I've
gotten some of the best lips from even your >> That's wrong.
I think >> you're wrong. No, mother.
>> Zena's like Zena when when this person called her like
a a nappyhaired monkey. Monkey 80 different iterations of monkey.
Oh, whatever. You were trolling. It's fine. Ice, you called me
Net, you son of a [__] IF YOU CALL ME NONTENT, you
son of a
I've done more content than that mother
times. You're crazy cuz he follows you around like a butt buddy.
But >> and you put him as S tier cuz it's funny and you
know goddamn well I've done more content than that boy and you
know that so I don't want to hear it. >> Shuy's better
content. >> In what way? Well,
>> that's not remotely true. Except Shuy does have his
unique his own unique aura that allows him to be both content
and content at the same time. Okay, he's Shui is a little unique.
He's still not as good as Zena cuz of how he interacts with other
people, but just watching Shuy interact with the with the world
is like an experience. It's like they thought a caveman and he
just is baffled by everything around him trying to make sense
of the world. Okay, it's awesome.
He goes out of his way to do creative >> He follows you
around like a what is creative besides that? Where what is the
content? I REALLY WANT TO KNOW. WHY ISN'T he viral online? Why
is Juvie only popping MPA? Why is Juvie only good on kick? Where's
his Twitter? Where's his Instagram? Where's his online motion?
Why is Zena on every other thing popping? And when you say Zena,
you know who the is, but you don't know who Shulie is.
>> Zena got a [laughter] >> The POINT IS I'M STILL
>> CUFF HIM LIKE I get that about that, bro. And you know
that. >> Okay. Who is Paul defending? Paul, who were you
defending in that fight just
>> Well, I mean, you should.
>> Uh, Gunniverse, thank you for the gifted sub. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. >> Calling people monkeys. >> Okay,
so exactly. >> But Zena is a little crazy as well. >> Zena.
Okay. What is she called? >> Zena and I are good. >> Hey,
what is Zena? >> A crazy stupid
woman.
>> I am. >> Exactly. That's exactly what you can
>> what was that? >> Yo, no.
>> I said I said Majesty. >> That's not what you
just said.
>> You just said the hard R.
what else? And he said, "Yeah, >> like [clears throat]
I give a >> No, I didn't say the
I called you. I called you the majesty of
something women and stuff."
>> What did you get you?
>> You know what he called me on Christmas morning? Did
I tell you that? And he wanted to cry about me saying I love
Sneakmore. And then he wanted to make sure I was Darius. That's
what he got me on Christmas morning. It was a [__]
Dude, dude. Why? Does
>> for 3 hours of >> That's what he got me. >> It's
your card. >> If you want the truth,
>> so nothing.
>> What did other people give you? >> Where did we
got the >> We had another hour on the stream. I just didn't
add it. So, okay. We have uh 13 subs. That's 65 bucks. That's
two more hours in the stream. I need to add that extra hour.
Let's go. Let's go.
>> Anything good? >> Yes. The Holy Bible. That's
like one of the best Christmas presents to get.
>> It's a coloring one that I can color in. Like there's
like beautiful like scriptures and stuff to color and >> I
I like it. >> Why is she getting you the Bible for >> Happy
New Year. >> My mother's very spiritual. >> What's
going on here? >> I grew up on the Bible, on the Quran,
on the Torah, all of that. >> Then why are you a witch?
>> I mean, I grew up on multiple religions. That's why
I'm a witch. >> The Quran and the Toran. >> The Quran,
the Torah, and the Bible.
I'm 75.
>> Nobody's counting.
>> No, you're not. >> I am. >> You said you're
Mexican.
>> I never said I was Mexican. >> You're Mexican
and I never >> and African. >> I never said I was
Mexican, dude. >> What are you? >> I'm not Mexican.
>> All right. What are you? >> I'm not Mexican.
>> You know I'm not Mexican. >> I was giving you
a compliment about your Christmas gift to your girl cuz I thought
it was like one of the WS. >> I don't know where you are.
Then what are you? >> You're calling me Mexican. >> Okay.
Then what are you? You said >> I'm French, Nigerian, El
Salvador, uh, BU people and Ghana. I'm not Mexican.
>> B, two people. Who the [__] even knows >> I'm
not. No. Ghana. >> I'm black and El Salvador. >> I
thought you were Mexican. >> I'm not Mexican. >> I'm
Italian. >> Yeah, I know. You're Tell the truth. >> How
are you? How are you if you're El Salvador and and uh black?
>> Who kept the slaves, Paul? Tell the
>> I don't know. Black people. >> Who kept the slaves?
dumb was on Twitter saying she was up at night but deleted the
tweet. >> So you and me are of the same kindred
>> You're because you're a you're a slave. >> I'm
demanding more respect. No, I'm just >> I don't What are
you saying? >> I'm I'm part Jewish, but I'm not 75%. I'm
only 20. >> What does that got to do with slaves?
>> What do you think?
>> I don't know. Did people have slaves? I don't know.
>> I'm not going to let you flip for me anymore, sir. I'm
no longer CS on BAU. >> What's BAU? Bang. It's It's ice.
>> Listen, you're not Jew. You're black. >> I'm I
am part Jew. I'm 20% Oscar
>> No, you're not. >> Yes, I am. I showed you I I
showed you my ancestry.com. It said I was 3%. And then when I
did 23 me, it said I was 70%. So, I don't know what's real, but
I'm I'm
>> Well, that nose doesn't say
nose.
>> Yeah, like a black one.
I know.
>> He just said I have a black person nose. >> No,
I You don't. >> But he just said I have a black person.
>> No, she actually doesn't. >> Just She definitely
has a white nose. >> Those nostrils are black. >> These
are black nostrils. Those are not >> He said my nostrils
are black as you know. I understand. We like have this thing
where we hate each other lowkey,
>> but you be trolling me randomly. >> I don't hate
you. >> You randomly be trolling me. >> Yeah, I troll
you. Like you and Chi are soul names. >> I troll everyone.
No, I was being serious when I said that. >> I'm I'm messaging
Zena. I'm trying to get her on stream right now. >> Every
day I think Paul is redeemable. Paul is a good guy deep down.
We need his sociopathic narcissistic
>> We control. >> Are you Are you want to get into
this? Do you I'm drunk as I'll really crash out right now. I
really >> I'm not a sociopath. >> You're a sociopath.
Yes, you are. And everybody knows it. You're a narcissistic sociopath.
>> Everybody knows every quip about you is you crashing
out being a sociopath. Want to control everybody around you.
Bro, you're a narcissistic sociopathic
>> That's not sociopathic. Are you legally smart? No. Pause.
Call. If you could people, do you understand that? I know for
a fact you would be a serial killer. >> And I know that
for a fact. If legally you could people, you would probably have
like 40 bodies by now. And I know that about you. You're a sociopathic
narcissistic mother, bro. And the only person that grounds you
is your female. >> No, she doesn't. >> Yes. If you
didn't have that, you'd be on the deep end. You would be crashing
out being the worst mother the whole >> Zena is not very
good at this. Zena shouldn't do therapy. Zena is not good at
this at all. >> What happens when you try to ground me?
Wait, I just walked into her saying that you people it was legal.
Wouldn't you do that though? >> Kimberly actually gets
grounded. I turned off the power in her room one night because
she annoyed me. >> What do we Wait, what are
>> That's a weird thing to just put on >> What are
you actually talking about? Are you fighting right now or what?
>> Ask her. >> He said he turned off the power in
your >> I don't want to like I thought we were going to
have fun. >> Well, you're best friend here. >> That's
like weird. It's just such a weird thing to That's like
>> trying to >> I don't know what you guys describe
that he's a sociopath and narcissistic sometimes majority of
the time. >> No, I'm not a sociopath. I try to >> self-proclaim
yourself as a social.
see. Didn't M do that. Didn't Miz do that with the Wi-Fi?
[snorts] He might be He might be He might be Emmy Ruinger. Oh
god. Oh god. [laughter] >> We'll know for sure if Ice Poseidon
has the telltale abuse signs. Okay, we can tell if he got hit
in the face with a plushy recently. Okay, we'll know for >> things
because it's smart.
>> Is that not narcissism? >> No, it's smart because
I have people like you around me.
>> Now you think I'm
>> And how am I? >> Because you're an emotional wreck.
>> Why do you put DBR? A cuz I agree with >> Yeah,
DBR is a chicken Andy. He's funny but he's not that funny. So
B.
Like are you basing this on the effort they put forth or or they're
like just like just like what they
CX sphere tier list. Eh, has he put Zena up here? Where's Zena?
Oh, he put Z he put Zena in F. He was lying.
He was lying.
>> Oh no. >> I don't know cuz like I do feel like
I am capable of the people. >> That's uh
Wait, who is this? I thought isn't this this isn't um uh Gary
David, is it? That's not who this is. I'm basing this all base
on their strengths. Solely their strength is Gary spend >> his
He's gonna be a D cuz he went to Afghanistan. He was on [snorts]
>> Let's see. >> Yeah. See, like your community is
going to put Carl higher than me every single
>> They just are. >> They're basing it on the person,
not the streams. I'm basing it on >> Action Man is S tier.
I watched an Action Man stream for a little bit the other day.
He legitimately seemed like he was like, "This guy is
legitimately unwell." And I don't mean mentally. He's like physically
unwell. He looks like he's going to vomit. Like 50% of the time
he's streaming at home. I think he just gets insanely hammered
when he streams at home. Like he looked like he was going to
puke the entire like 10 minutes I watched and then I clicked
through the the stream previously and he looks like he's going
to vomit the entire time.
He makes me cry laughing. He does have moments where he's funny.
He is very capable of being funny. I was just I was watching
him like, "Dude, you are beyond hammered right now." It's
>> on the streams. See, I'll put I would put Moises. >> I'm
trying to get Zena to hop on, by the way. I keep telling her
she's dodging. He's dodging. She's dodging. She's >> on
an S if he did
streams, but he never does. So, he's really a B. Uh cuz he's
still funny even at the desktop, but he's uh he could be an S.
>> I I agree. I think Moyes could be S. I think there's
only a handful of people that make me genuinely laugh out loud.
like actually laugh. And I do think Moyes is one of them. At
the top, you got S, you got you, Action Man, Shuy, then A, you
got me, Nick, DBR, Joelle, and then B, ABZ, Tazo, Chicken, Andy,
Moises, Nick Lee. Yeah. No, I'm tuned. Okay. Pathetic Gary. Pathetic.
And Gary
that you have to go grab Goer and put him in I don't know/donent
cuz you don't want to actually put him where you'd really put
him with ice right there.
Oh, that is sad.
That is very, very sad. He's laughing to
>> Yeah. No, I'm too Okay. Me and you are on the same page.
I'm not going to No, take it back. >> Embarrassing. Tries
to tries to sneak Goar out of the list without even without even
saying anything. Just get him out of there. Just I don't want
to talk about it with I don't I don't want to bring up his name
around ice. I don't want to do that.
>> All right. >> Sam is not sad. I mean, Sam, you
know, he when he was streaming on kick, he was traveling. He
was always doing something. He does his I mean, he he puts in
like a lot of work. Uh he's not funny at all, but I think the
places that he
>> Shuy is funny unintentionally, Gummy Verse. Like, Shuy
on that island trying to steal somebody's canoe was some of the
funniest content I've ever seen in my life because of how bad
he was at it the whole time. Like, it was unironically so hilarious.
He wasn't trying to be funny. I do admit that he tries things
which is probably good for generating content too. Like he he
actually spends his money. He doesn't just like sit at home.
So there there are like some very very very funny Shuy moments.
Okay. Yeah. Where he like he rubs his face with mud while he
is wearing an orange life vest. Like a fluorescent orange life
vest. He's like trying to camouflage himself while wearing like
hunter safety gear in the form of a life jacket. Is so funny.
He's like rubbing mud on his face.
And you know, there's no way he could plan that. He didn't mean
for that. He was like literally trying to camouflage himself
while wearing the orange life jacket. Just this fluorescent thing
that you couldn't possibly mistake him through the bushes.
So funny, dude. >> He goes are very interesting.
>> I would agree. Like shout out Sam, but I would put him
on probably like realistically
give him like a I give him an A. I give him an A, but not S.
out of the all the I think you're I hate to say it, but I think
you're you're the only S. My opinion. >> Well, action man,
he is a >> dude. Gary. Okay,
I the only thing I can really say or appreciate from Gary David
here is the complete lack of gag reflex. Okay, I don't know how
he's speaking correctly with ice besides stuffed all the way
down his throat. Holy [__] >> Good streamer.
He is funny. He's just uh not very creative, which does not do
well for him. So, you know what? You're right. A for him. Shui
is creative and he's funny. Um, he's very stupid though, but
I think that works in his favor. Uh, and then yeah, Sam, he travels
and and I do enjoy the the traveling that like to like Africa
and these random places that he goes. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, yeah. Chad, would you agree with this list or what
do you think? I think you're helping me out a little bit here
by putting me A because I don't think most people would put me
>> No. You know, here's here's the thing, Gary. You're
A because you're good at desktop streaming. You're good at any
form of streaming that I can think of. IRL, desktop, whatever.
You're good at talking. You're good at narrating, coming up with
new things to say that are interesting. You know, when you do
commentary on like riots and stuff. Um, and then when you do
IRL, you're high energy, talkative, willing to go above and beyond.
Like on the scavenger hunt, you're streaming like 20 hours a
day. And then when you're in a group of people, that's where
you shine because the group of people will do
and then your reactions to the is just it's super funny because
you're like a normal guy. >> Yeah. How do I get other people
to put me at A as well? I like I feel like to get like your community
to put me at an A, I feel like I would have to
go a bit above and beyond my my comfort zone. And I think that's
the only way. Like I feel like if I just stay comfortable and
I just do things that like I think are funny or like I don't
think they'll ever really appreciate me that way. >> I
didn't miss them like commenting on Zeno right at the beginning,
did I? I might have.
Hold on. Let me go I don't need this anymore. Let me go back
to the beginning. I might have missed just like some immediate
commentary on Zeno. PBR A cuz I agree with that. >> I
a >> Oh, does he do the same thing he did with Goon where
he just sneaks Zena out without saying anything.
Gay.
Gay. Very gay. Very gay. Very gay
>> If you to be an S tier, >> no to be a community,
>> bro. My community, listen, they they
don't know everything, okay? I'm telling you that you are an
A streamer. When you're put in the right circumstances, you are
an A streamer. Now, if you never did IRL ever and you only did
desktop, I would bring you down to like a C. >> Uh-huh.
All right. So, you think the balance is good? >> Because
you're not like super funny on desktop. Like, I'm not laughing
out loud when you're on desktop, but you're just interesting
to listen to. Um, but when you're doing IRL in a group of people,
I would put you an A because you make me laugh out loud. And
then Nick White, you know, he's funny. I like him. DBR is funny.
Joelle funny and goes to crazy places. SJC's funny. Kimberly's
hilarious. Um, and then Action Man's funny. And then the Btier
streamers are like the reliable ones. Not funny, but very reliable.
Moyes is funny, but he doesn't really do anything most of the
time, so he can't be any higher. But you know, ABC, Tazo, Chicken,
Andy, Nicki, these are reliable streamers. They're always live.
Never. They're never not live. So A, so S is everything. A is
funny. B is reliable. C is like side character energy where like
they have some some funny quips that they'll like throw in here
and there. D is just camera angle. Uh and then F is
no more than
just being used for >> Damn. I think Hondro I think Hondro
like has a good like you you and Handre have like a nice little
banter which act is S tier. Dude, I maybe I just miss all the
good action man content. I guess he has viewers,
but again, I watched I watched a little bit of a monkey stream
and he just looked like he's going to puke the whole time, >> which
is funny.
Like he makes me laugh when he's like he always like makes like,
you know, he digs at you, which is like his little >> thing.
Handro. Yeah, with me. We have our little banters, whatever.
Like he could be Btier because he's reliable, but the problem
is his camera angles are >> I mean, everyone just films
their face nowadays. Nobody tries to like really have good camera
angles.
>> No. Like that's that's half of why most half the people
here are f because of their camera angles. Mo like if they had
better cam camera angles they would be higher. Like Black Dave
is funny. I like him. He has good content. But his camera angles
sometimes are just so bad that I can't watch it. Now if Sam if
we're going based on every S being everything then Sam would
be an A. >> With Hono was entertaining for other reasons.
Dude, that was depressing as >> not funny at all. He's
literally the most unfunny person I've ever met. >> I think
Sam's a B to be honest with you because I think his effort that
he puts forth and who he is makes him a B, but I don't think
the entertainment value is enough to make him an A. And I think
OB, >> bro, did they did they just cut Darius entirely
off this list? Am I missing where Darius is? Where's Darius?
Is Dar Oh no, he's there. They put him in Oh god,
bro. I don't think that's fair, man. I think Darius has good
content.
That's not fair.
Dude, Darius is way funnier than a bunch of these people.
Objectively speaking, you could say the same about me to where
like I don't put I don't put the effort. >> Darius sucks
without Zena. No, I don't think so.
I don't think so. I think Darius is capable of being funny without
Zena. It's just Darius has never been funny. No, Darius. Darius
Darius is capable of being funny. Again, not necessarily intentionally.
He's not like funny. He's not doing comedy. He's not making witty
jokes. That's not why Darius is funny.
It's not It's not real. It's not like it's not that. Okay.
People don't like Darius cuz he got into fights with these guys
and and that's why Dude, this is like the this is like the propaganda
list. I guarantee you if I look down at these people, there are
other people down here who like ice off for some reason. There
has to be a couple of them, right? Cuz Darius, Zena, and I guess
Goon goes over here. You just make your fun watching people ruin
their lives and suffer. No, I wait. I like Darius when he's having
fun, too. Darius Darius winning is funny, too.
Uh, I happen to laugh when he's suffering because he's suffering
from the same things that have been ruining his life all of the
time,
but I love when Darius is winning.
It's very funny.
I find it very amusing. All right, I think that's it for all
this stuff. I'm trying to make some content happen on the side
here. We're I'm just
I'm trying to see
Oh, whoops.
Watch this real quick again.
>> Give me two seconds while I try to figure this out.
>> Why are YOU
>> WHY are you racist? >> Because she CALLED ME RACIST
THING. SHE CALLED ME AN EVIL MONKEY. She called me a 30. >> Oh,
she calls you racy.
I want to make the mad like look at you. Look at you. >> You
funny looking. You shake like a goddamn I can't even say the
word. >> Read your chat. Tell them. >> They said
you're worse than Kayn.
>> You're worse than What? What did you What did you say
to Zena? >> What did you say to Zena? What did you say
to Zena?
>> Oh my god. What did you say to Zena?
>> She's She's actually
>> I don't know who is. What did you say to
>> Here's one. Big blackie. Here's one. Let me take off
the log. [__] YOU. EAT THIS
after I tell them to leave. >> Damn. Tell her to say what
she said to >> I mean, yeah. I mean, if she wants you to
leave, then go.
>> Which one? >> What do you mean?
>> Oh, you actually messaged her, Ginger. Nice.
I'm trying to message her the link, but I can't I have to like
add her. She has to see that I added her from this account. I
don't have her as a friend. I have her as a friend on the account
she was on like seven days ago, but on this one, I don't. Oh,
now I have her as a friend. Never mind. Wait, yes, I did. Oh,
wait. What?
She just showed up in my friends and then she doesn't show up
in my friends now. Wait, what? Oh, I'm misreading Discord. God
damn it. Yeah. Oh, I was looking at the pending screen. I'm Never
mind. Never mind. I was looking at the pending screen, not the
regular screen. I was looking at my pending friend requests,
not my actual friend me.
>> She didn't She didn't have me. So, I'm just trying to
get her to hop on's going to cover these DMs.
I'll pull them up now. Hold on. I was going to wait for Lav to
come back, but she's not coming back and she wanted me to do
this. So, in in Lav's honor, I'll just pull these up. Okay,
so Lav for some reason reached out to Zena and said, "Hey, I
know there's beef because of the Kimmy situation, but you're
the coolest literally ever. And every clip I see of you is an
inspiration, and I will always be a diehard fan." Hello. Who's
this?
>> It's me.
>> How'd you know to hop on right now?
Um cuz I just got off the phone fighting with my husband, so
I'm back. >> Oh, so cool. Okay.
>> Is that why he ended his stream with like 800 viewers?
>> Uh I don't know why he ended his stream. He was on like
his period or something. Don't know. >> Oh, so cool. All
right. Yeah, he got I told someone I told someone in chat to
cam up because he was Indian and he was saying stuff about women
>> and uh my husband said that optically that looked like
I was trying to get in a voice call with another man and it made
him look weird. So
Yeah, never mind. He caused that >> some goofy
super rad. And then he like publicly disrespected me which was
like super cool. Um but anyway,
>> Yeah, go ahead. >> That's crazy.
Okay. Anyway, so Zena responds to you. You weirdass [__]
The audacity even think you could hit me the up at all is crazy.
You clout chasing.
And I know your stalker. Watch the clips of my best friend defending
me. So you know we [__] tight. Don't text me hoe
cuz you know I'm a jailbird. Play stupid games. Win prizes. And
of course you're pathetic. You're a pathetic ass fan. You always
been a fan. I should do this in I should do this in my low tier
god accent. My uh
wait, what was the what was the guy's name? Evil My Evil Fossil
accent. I should try to get that. You gonna stay a fan? You a
diehard Kimmy fan? Die on
I adore you. Wow. I was giving Zena the opportunity to come on
and defend why she's being such a in these messages.
>> Well, because she doesn't like me because of the Kimmy
thing.
>> Yeah, but is that really enough?
Yeah, she's like
>> listen, if everybody was like that, then wouldn't Fresh
and Fit have not taken her back
after everything she leaked about Sneo? If if you leaking some
about one of someone's friends means those people have to disavow
you forever, then wouldn't Fresh and Fit have like never taken
Zena back?
She leaked a bunch of [__] about their friend
and they took her back cuz they're friends. Everyone can be friends.
No. No. Ride or die is gay. You can you can forgive people. Okay.
That's always true. Especially when I'm floundering for content
at
like 3:00 a.m. Okay. Especially then. But most times also you
can just forgive people and be friends. But it goes doubly when
I'm currently floundering and don't have any content. What Kimmy
thing? Wait. Sweatpants. You don't know the history between Kimmy
and Lav? You don't know that history? Oh, well, Lav leaked that
Kimmy
Lav's husband before Lav and her husband got together, but while
sort of her and Ice beside him were on a break
and they kind of rubbed it in Ice's face and then Ice kind of
got called a well is still called a come for it unfortunately.
>> Give me one second to finish typing this paragraph to
my husband and then I'll I'll speak.
>> Sorry. Just uh just you know buy time. >> Feel
free to feel free to not me mention it again on stream. You just
don't mention the cuz people will bring it up. >> Oh, no.
He publicly embarrassed me on stream. So, he's going to he he
will be hearing from me. He will be hearing about it. >> That's
fine. He can hear from you. Um,
yeah, that's fine. He can hear from you. And Ice is back with
her. I thought it could never happen. Wow. >> Okay. Anyway,
yeah, I Me and Zena were cool for like forever. I always whenever
I saw her in person,
I was like, "You are so beautiful." Like she I I'm I've always
been a big Zena fan. Um, and when she was going through the stuff
with Darius and um, even at the beginning with Shuy, I like reached
out to be like, "Hey, hope that everything's like okay. I saw
you crying on stream. Like, I've been there, girl." Like, she's
reached out to me and like was like, "Hope you're doing okay
after your miscarriage." Like things were like totally fine.
And then I um outed Kimmy for like having sex with uh Tim years
ago and uh because Kimmy was like a rancid to me. But it doesn't
really matter what
the what the uh the And I you know it's it's really funny because
I like everyone saw I don't know if you watched the full clip
but like that's she gets like crazy and deranged and like that's
how she was to me like randomly after I was like super nice to
her. Um but Zena gains too much from being close friends with
Kimmy. So her loyalties are are there and uh that's fine. I'm
I'm a ride or die too. like if someone was messing with one of
my girls, I would not be buddy buddy. I messaged her because
I thought it would be funny to do it and I I did wonder what
she would say and I thought her response was funny. It's like
when you pay to uh it's like you know those restaurants that
you go to and people are like really uh mean to you and you can
like tip so that they like slap you in the face.
>> No idea what you're talking about. But >> you've
never heard about those? >> I I get the concept. I sort
of get the concept. Never heard of it in >> Well, that's
what I did. I'm such a big fan of Zena. I got like a I got like
a fan interaction
with Zena.
>> Damn. Where's uh
where's this junk drawer tweet? Hold on a second. Going to retweet
the guy who did the um the Dioro
Retweet this. It's a good video. Give me two seconds. I'll be
right back. I just got to go to my door real quick. Be right
back. Ginger Ramoth, about
50% of your chats in this Discord are about how evil you think
I am. You can actually turn off the stream when I'm here.
You have agency. You have agency.
>> Actually surprised Lab wasn't racist when talking about
Zena. I'm not racist >> words really trailed off there.
Really petered out. I'm not racist towards
>> I'm not racist towards black women. >> Oh, okay.
But Zena is going to do that.
>> That was terrible. That's not funny.
That was terrible. Who did Who just did that? Junarch, do better.
That was
>> that was awful. Okay. I
>> will be real. I would have to do major switch-ups right
now. I just think it's crazy that Zena ran. >> I've never
seen Zena run before, but she literally ran.
>> Oh, for what? You wanted her to talk to >> Well,
I I was just going to talk to her and then she
ran. >> No, she's doing She's too big for this community
now.
She's riding the the
>> same size she was before. >> Nice Poseidon stuff.
>> Oh, there's no way. No, there's no way she'll refuse
to come on cuz she's trying to be friends with Destiny. That's
not possible. Zena's more powerful than that. I don't I don't
know what I can tell you what the conversation would be like.
She would say exactly the same things that she
to me in that message. And then I' and then I'd be like, "You're
right. That's true. Love you, girl." Like I don't I Zena's like
she's like an enigma. You can't even really like argue with her.
You just got to love her. You just got to love her through it.
Yeah. I'm a fan. I would know.
>> Like what could I possibly say even in that message?
Like what am I going to like I what would I even say?
No, you're wrong.
Like what? Yeah, I was watching the I was watching the thing
that went viral, babe. Yeah, I was watching the thing that went
viral
and I love you. I'm a big fan. Yeah, I'm a fan of you. Yes. >> Oh,
I literally didn't see. Apparently, she didn't want to come out
before. I've just wasting my time. Well,
boring. Um, >> got to hit her with the no you laugh.
>> So boring. Okay. Um,
>> I don't know if I want to change
here. >> I don't think she did that.
>> What do we want to change attack to?
>> I think that every 19-year-old male should be
taken under the care of a 30-year-old
woman. You know, I do have I do have some thoughts on on the
drama. I think you know what's so crazy is it's hard to remember
that everyone in this room is 31 to 40 years old.
>> Uh, no that's not hard to remember. They look about
that age pretty much obvious the entire time they're interacting.
>> Yeah. I just think this is what happens when women don't
get pregnant and have families by like 30 is they just like get
drunk and like get in each other's faces. I've I've never done
anything like this and it it embarrasses me
Have you been following any of the Minnesota? Not Minnesota.
Well, yes, Minnesota. The the fraud, the childcare fraud. Cuz
remember,
>> We got a son review of this. You haven't? Wait, really?
What kind of racist are you? The whole community of black people
stealing welfare money from everyone. Allegedly. Allegedly. Um,
I might watch Hassan's video. I want >> That's the main
point. >> I want to see if Hassan is gonna sweep.
Is this song gonna sweep?
Brutal Segue. [laughter] Hold on. Even if this were true, Ginger,
it wouldn't this be like totally.
>> uh Why did >> your husband's career cuz a man
called you stupid? Dude,
my husband has more viewers than he's ever had.
And there was no anti-hero in the Ice Poseidon streams. Now,
every time Ice Poseidon has any event, Tim streams it, gets
quadrupled the amount of viewers he would have gotten going to
the events, makes 10 times more money, gets to build a platform
off of being an anti-hero, off of not being a sucker to some
random
like you are.
>> I think Gunnar gets reasonable views when he's not talking
about the ice beside and stuff and then he could get more if
he's doing ice beside drama.
>> Yeah. No, but like when he was doing like during the
scavenger hunt or like dur during Hunger Games he was like a
200 to 500 viewer Andy and now anytime Ice has an event and has
like 5,000 viewers, Tim has like 1,200 going over it. I do think
anti-hero is pushing it pretty far.
>> You thought about Snarker? He's the He's the CX community
snarker. He's snarking on the CX community. Thought about this
>> No, I I'm not really I'm not in the snark scene. I I
I know a little bit about a little bit, but
>> he mostly just snarks on the CX streams. Okay.
Jesus creeper, dude.
Listen, it's one of those things that it does suck, but all these
terms are just brain damaged in general. So, what about string
puller? No. No.
I'm going to put some music on in the
I've got nothing to really pivot to, so I'm just trying to fill
out time here. I didn't hit play on the stream when we went before.
It's 30 minutes. We got 30 minutes. Trying to figure out another
direction I want to go in.
Um, basically this Somalian stuff they found it like a pattern
of Somalian people who are starting daycare, home
uh, what else is it like? basically a bunch of like smaller health
care or social care businesses in Minnesota
and a bunch of them
are basically the people are alleging fraud and there's not really
proof of fraud but it does seem like quite a few of these businesses
have been written up a ton and seem to not be getting like
ever see they just seem to never get closed or they get closed
they get their licenses revoked and they register under a new
name at the same address with the same logo and get put back
into business again.
Literally, there seems to be no oversight of like, hey, you actually
lost your license,
you can't have this business anymore. It's like, they'll just
register it either in in the same address under like a different
name. It'll be the same business,
right? And then they start doing the same violations. They keep
getting the same violations.
I don't know. It's kind of
Dollar General in that medical plaza. Well, people call it a
I don't think that's enough to say it's not a medical plaza because
you never know what the like it basically could they could have
storefronts, right, that are a part of that plaza. And maybe
it kind of makes sense. It's the oldest loophole ever. Well,
sure.
But basically, as you would expect, everybody who's left of center
is saying that it's incredibly racist to blame Somalians for
this and it's obviously just like right-wing grifting. And then
all the right-wingers are like, "Actually, there's a hundred
billion dollars in fraud. It's like all of the fraud." I think
Asmin Gold tweeted there's probably a trillion dollar in trillion
dollars in immigrant fraud happening in the US.
You get people all over the political spectrum on it. It is pretty
fun to cover in my opinion.
Think about covering some of the Hassan stuff right now. Yeah,
I probably just could cover it. [clears throat] Oh,
we could also do Dude, I've seen some wild body cam footage recently.
Just some crazy.
Feels like that could be good.
Trying to think of if that's what I want to do.
See the Griffin gaming mod drama. Nope. No idea what that is.
What is this? >> I have to go eat, but I have sleep in
the morning and I need to fight with my husband. See you guys.
>> To go eat, but I have sleep in the morning. I have to
go eat, but I have sleep in the morning
and I fight with my husband. Goodbye. Very police department
said there was no danger to the public. This is This is >> She
has to go eat.
I got it. >> Woman at the center of the case. 57year-old
Kathleen Mayo. She was found dead inside her apartment more than
a month ago. And it took more than a week for police to identify
a suspect and they did so only after he called them. >> Are
you sure this is like the same thing you linked me?
Whatever the [__] you Is this what you linked me?
You just linked me this.
Is this what
what is this? Murder investigation in Low Tree, Colorado raises
questions about public safety. >> These details, they didn't
add up. So, your investigator Karen Morphett started digging.
And it turns out there is a lot more to this story. >> Yeah,
Karen. This case certainly disturbing. Neighbors that you spoke
with tell you that they felt left in the dark about just how
real this danger was and so close to them. Yeah. And neighbors
that we spoke with say that waiting for information was really
nerve-wracking and stressful. A question and question if their
safety was more at risk than they were led to believe during
that investigation. I requested the suspect's arrest warrant
which shows a timeline detailing what police knew and when. >> Okay.
Did some music >> like something out of a popular TV show.
>> But I finally just have to accept it. I'll always be
alone. In a murder suspect's arrest warrant, he claims to be
a fan of the serial killer drama
Troy Marcus Reynolds lived upstairs.
>> Not what I was expecting. >> From his alleged
victim while being questioned by police, he describes himself
as reclusive.
>> Is it just me or we get more
>> weird ass shaped heads in media nowadays?
There's so many people like there's literally just this weird
sphereing going on. This used to happen. I don't even know what's
going on, man. >> Liking violent video games and interacting
with others only through social media. >> I'd never seen
this guy. Yeah. So, like the second day there was a tape here.
>> Madison Dile lives next door to the >> They said
it was suspicious and that was all we got, but that we were safe.
On August 24th, the victim was last seen walking on the property
alone with her two dogs.
>> September 4th, police discover her body. Officers find
distinct lacerations to the neck and a hand possibly missing.
Even more disturbing, a symbol drawn in blood.
The very next day, police issue a Facebook post. The death is
a suspected homicide, but that there's no known danger to the
public. Lone Tree sent the same notice to CBS Colorado, then
reiterated there was no known danger to the public in a follow-up
email. >> They had asked me if I had noticed anything the
night before home, and I was like, "No, >> my partner."
>> So, this guy's a mod for some streamer. I don't even
know who Griffin Gaming is, >> asked like multiple times
if like we should be concerned about anything.
CBS Colorado's review of the investigation timeline shows 2 days
after that body is discovered, the unknown suspect returns to
the scene, leaving the same symbol. Who is the murderer?
The murderer here.
>> No. Yeah, the murderer is a mod for some. They said
he doesn't interact with anybody except online. He's literally
never interacted with any of his >> Found in the victim's
bedroom, known only to police. And all of those saw way was blocked
on that other end. Her doors right there. And then like right
here, there was like a huge like maybe like that big around that
height.
September 7th, apartment management alerts residents to the investigation.
Later that night, Reynolds calls 911, telling dispatch the 57year-old
woman, that was me. It's obvious. He was detained, denied any
involvement, and then was released, and returned to the complex.
A second Facebook post to the community from Lone Tree Police
came on September 8th, confirming the death was officially a
>> Did they just let this guy go? Wait, did he call from
his own number and said it was me? And then he was like, "Actually,
never mind. It wasn't me." And they're like, "Okay, you're free
to go." >> Homicide and releasing the victim's name, Kathleen
Mayo. They asked the public for tips, but still made no mention
of any threat. >> I don't know. Feels like they shouldn't
have been telling us that we were like totally safe. [laughter]
>> On September 9th, Reynolds was arrested for an unrelated
case. He's questioned about 13 large knives and an autopsy saw
similar to this one that were found in his apartment. When police
questioned him about why he had the saw, he said he was a collector.
They asked if it was bought for a specific reason. He laughs
and said no. It
wasn't until September 12th when police announced Reynolds was
officially charged with firstdegree murder in the death of Kathleen
Mayo.
>> Did you buy this for a specific reason?
>> Now, we did ask Lone Tree. >> What was that suspiciously
murderous laugh you just did? That seems very concerning to me.
police how they determined there was no known danger in this
case and in general. In a statement, a spokesperson said in part,
"It was based on what investigators learned the day the victim
was found." And quote, "At the time, it wasn't confirmed whether
this was a homicide and there was no evidence suggesting any
danger to the residents or the public." Adding that quote, "The
information we had indicated this was an isolated incident and
there was no reason to believe anyone else was at risk." The
Lone Tree Police Chief added to those comments in part saying
he knows people want information, but that they can't share every
detail without risking a case. Karen and Michael, he says at
the end of the day, an arrest was made and they believe that
they have the right person behind bars. >> Certainly scary
though for all the >> Yeah. How do they feel about this?
I mean, that has to be frightening for >> Yeah. You heard
Madison there. She obviously thinks that she would have done
some things differently had she known the extent of what they
found. Um, but we did talk to other neighbors who didn't want
to go on camera. And one woman tells me that she now has severe
anxiety, has trouble sleeping, and even suffers from panic attacks
because of how traumatic this was for her over that time and
just seeing police there. And again, she didn't want to go on
camera. Um, but certainly, you know, there are different varying
feelings about how this was handled. >> Yeah, certainly.
So, all right, Karen, thank you for looking into it. >> Wait,
where do you find out that this guy's the mod for the YouTuber?
Hold on.
This is old. This isn't that old. It's like six months old. Give
me a second.
I think I open this guy's YouTube channel up. It's apparently
a mod for this guy. >> The first time a guy sees a girl.
>> Realize that dreamer. >> What's up, guys? I hope
you all are having a great day today. Just full of so much positiv.
>> Was this the X drama? Oh, there's just like some drama
at their New Year's party. Wasn't that interesting to be
How do we know he's the mod? Well, Moody Morgan said he is. So,
I'm like waiting for Moody Morgan to fill in anything else, but
I'll look on Twitter. She gave me a video that has no tie to
him and was like, "This guy's the mod." One, spoiling the content,
and then two,
not even giving me any context for why this guy's a mod. Crazy.
Absolutely crazy. Which of your mods do you think is most likely
to go on a spree? Uh, it's probably you, Kger. I'll be real.
Did you just make that up and leave?
I thought it was crazy that this guy's like clearly like an anime.
He's trying to be like an anime villain. RP an anime
and then he
peeled out.
It was in Chud's inbox, so it must be true. Weird. That is a
weird metric for determining what's true.
Okay. Um,
Let me see here.
Dude, the only the only thing I have to pivot to is more Somali,
and I don't really want to pivot to more Somali [__]
dude. Let me see. Let me see what's going on. Let me see if there's
some
going on in the normal watering holes.
>> XQC says that Nick Shirley's video is dog. It was >> corporate
filing and and refiling and updates on on on paperwork.
How what the do I know about that? YOU DON'T KNOW THIS EITHER.
WHAT THE? >> So the last bienium is some old GUY SHOW ME
TWO PIECES OF PAPER which
keeps pointing at it like guys LOOK AT MY PHONE LOOK GUYS LOOK
WHAT TIME IT IS. Jesus man look at the time man. >> Oh
his his
criticism is just stupid
You can look up this stuff. This is like this is the worst criticism.
There's so many things that are bad. He's like taking the the
one piece of evidence they have that they've actually sourced
from somewhere real and that's what he's complaining about. He
must have better complaints than this. >> Yeah, dude. Do
you get this? Holy [__] Like what the [__]
>> There is like a specific complaint. It's a You don't
know if it's the CCAP budget or the CCAP spending for the year.
>> That is one thing that's a problem. We had an $18 billion
surplus.
>> This bianium we have a $6 billion
deficit. That's a $24 billion swing in one bianium.
>> The is a bianium. By the way, I didn't ask this. >> How
in the [snorts] world can you burn through $24 billion in two
years? This is how a specified period of two years a huge part
of it. >> I said earlier fraud is bad. I am I guarantee
you that some of these are absolutely doing fraud. Maybe that
one is doing fraud. I I there is for sure some type of fraud
happening for sure. But is it Oh, is is this
is are these guys pointing at at the fraud happening? Are these
guys debunking the fraudulent? No. Are they passing the the bur
of proof? No. This is some dog.
This is dog [__] You say a lot of that is fraud that's
taking place here. >> I'm good with people having this
guy on.
Nobody realizes that this guy's an actual
he is actually like ADIQ cannot speak English. Like I think all
of these interactions are basically scripted and anytime he's
off a script he can barely stumble through a sentence.
It's actually hilarious to watch.
Let's see here. Where's Did they actually have him on? Like is
the content out? I could watch this. I could watch Nick Shirley
talk on camera all day. All day I could walk watch this guy talk
on camera. This guy is a complete [__] It is hilarious
to listen to him speak. Give me more.
Give me more
of this guy speaking.
Anything more I can get.
I love this guy speaking.
Hold on. Nick Shirley. Iced coffee
hour. Did they have him on yet? Nope. Last video is with Clav.
He'll be out within a week. Slow. Very slow. Let's see here.
What else do we got? What else do we got? Dude, this all sucks,
man. I just don't want to go dig fully into the Ohio fraud stuff
right now. It just feels like it would be a waste of time. Oh
my goodness. Hassan Colergate clip the >> People are going
to be very upset about this. Hassan says Colorate didn't have
I think he says people don't care about Colergate.
Do you see his mom? Did I see Nick Shirley's mom? I think I saw
that she was doing interviews or something defending him. Yeah.
Any question about the dog beast allegations of that older tail
pulling thing fake is crazy. >> We watched Turkey clad
video weeks ago at the same time that propaganda worked on my
brain. >> More like a week ago. >> What do you mean?
Uh older tail pulling thing fake. I don't know what you're talking
about. Whoa. No. I'm I'm abusive. I'm abusive to my dog. Um we
did the Oh, we didn't do Do you think Doctober 7 was your biggest
controversy to date? No. I think America deserved 911 is still
one that like has real world impact because
that one that one even though people don't give a [__]
about it
it's uh it's much easier to like uh virtue signal over uh it's
much
>> October 7th [laughter]
>> I think America deserve 91 that one actually there are
emotional >> it's basically just him saying it wasn't the
biggest the biggest controversy of the year he doesn't want to
it the big controversy.
Just say it was the biggest controversy, dude. 20 years after
the fact after we slaughtered,
you know, millions of of Arab people and whatnot. And
>> hold on. Can I show this? This is NOT A JOKE. THEY actually
want to kill me. In all seriousness, please include me in your
prayers. Joey Mountains. This is going to be you on April 27th,
2026 in a muddy ditch alongside the highway. Enjoy your last
couple of months, buddy.
Oh boy.
Wait, what was below that? Nick Shirley reveals he's facing serious
threats after exposing billions in alleged Minnesota fraud. There's
bounties on me here in Minnesota because people are so upset.
Oh boy, this like the full-on griff press.
This is crazy.
I don't care about I I I
don't care about him complaining about threats. It's like obviously
you're going to get threats. Everybody gets threats. I don't
think there's a bounty on your head. show evidence of that. Like
if you have evidence beyond random anonymous internet skits threatening
you, then you should do something about it. If it's just random
anonymous internet skits threatening you, then then I don't think
you can care that >> Most people see it as like what we
did after being awful. Um but as far as Doctober 7 goes,
it's one of those things where like
there are
Yeah. Americans over 911 will always have more staying power
even though people don't really give a [__] about
it. The October 7 on the other hand is uh utterly ridiculous.
But those who will forever those who will forever be like no
he's a [__] dog abuser that guy they will always
say it. Most people after a
uh most people after a while I think is at least in my in what
I have seen uh happen especially because like the Department
of Homeland Security Secretary literally slaughtered a puppy
like actually shot a puppy in the head and wrote about it in
a book and like you know ICE agents like dogs with regular frequency
before people say like oh what aboutism or whatever. It just
kind of shows that like people don't really give a [__]
and they only
they only give a [__] about it because it's like
uh something that they can get me on, right?
And yeah, there was a wow streamer that literally both things
those things are true. It's like
the thing that's lucky for Hassan is literally even if he did
shock his dog, it's not like he's abusive to the dog. You know
what I mean?
Like even if he did shock his dog, I don't think he's abusing
that dog. I think that dog is well taken care of. He easily could
have lost his temper there and used the the collar if the collar
was on and like tried to correct the dog with the collar cuz
he's because he lost his temper. He was impatient. He'd been
rattled cuz his stream got cut off,
That's possible. But even in the worst case scenario, I don't
think he's like that bad.
the probably the worst thing what most people would say is well
the persistent lying is what's worse and I can maybe agree with
that but I also I also understand how somebody like something
up and then they lie about it and could continue on with it.
Um I'm still and I realize people will hate this not 100% sure
the dog had the right color on like the shock color on not 100%
like 90%
but not 100%. like I think choked the out of his dog on stream
this year and not a single person said anything because nobody
cares. So,
um the the reason why uh like as far as as far as like people
bringing it up, they'll bring it up. Most people meme about it.
Like the overwhelming majority meme about it. It's not even like
a gotcha at this point. It's just a meme at this point. But um
the people that bring it up sincerely get really mad when I joke
about it cuz they'll be like, "Why are you guys why are you guys
joking about this?" Like, "Why are you joking? This is serious."
It's like, "Well, okay. If it's so serious, why did you [__]
make memes about it for like the first month, dumbass?" Long
comics book club.
If Assan [__] is the best that the left has to offer,
the male models were already lost. The man has more controversy
than buttons on a shot collar remote. Doing a good enough job.
>> It's never I just figured out like I hate you dog, you
shocked your dog, or whatever the [__] they've uh,
you know, made up. Uh, >> I hate you dog, you keep spamming
over and over again long after the meme has like [clears throat]
been dusted off. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Whatever.